at least the over 50s health and social
care workers
and people with underlying health
conditions will get
a booster dose in the autumn now at the
moment there's no evidence that
immunity is dropping off certainly if
you look at the hospitalization and the
death rate you would say
vaccines are still protecting people at
risk
even if they got their vaccine all the
way back in in december
and january but nevertheless you're
hearing today from the joint committee
on vaccinations and immunizations that
the nhs should
be ready just in case to give a booster
dose now the lots of
unanswered questions which vaccine when
and so on those details will become uh
clear
over the next few weeks but the jcvi
is saying be ready in september this is
what the health minister had to say
we have been considering a booster
vaccine and today we have received
interim advice from jcvi that's the
independent scientific advisors
to the government and they are
supporting that campaign
and they back our plans which are to
roll it out from september
this year onwards and really to do what
it takes to keep the virus
at bay that's the objective and they're
saying that
you should obviously start with the most
vulnerable first and that's our plan
but also alongside it offer the flu
vaccine at the same time
and deal with both of those at the same
time
but of course this is the time of year
that uh that gps and pharmacists would
be extremely busy in giving flu jabs and
it's likely that people would be given
the flu jab and the kovijab in separate
arms at the same time which might speed
things up but nevertheless
it's going to be a busy autumn for the
nhs yeah thomas thank you very much
indeed
let's get more now on the breaking news
i was bringing you a moment ago a court
has overturned bill cosby's sex assault
conviction after finding
an agreement with a previous prosecutor
uh prevented him
from being charged in the case sky's
martha kelner